fans of the game might have a plus 5
resistance to charm spells birds are
they Charmed by Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves here's what they
have to say what's a good time it is to
be a Dungeons and Dragons fan 23 years
after Courtney Solomon's critically
panned DND movie relegated the RPG
Classics live-action adaptations to
direct to DVD status Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves has captured
the best things about DND it's arrived
on the big screen with the kind of joy
and Adventure that bodes well for future
sequels critics and audiences rage
Jonathan Goldstein and John Francis
Daly's movie highly and the likable cast
begs for a magnificent party of
adventurous all of this is extremely
good publicity for the game and it
doesn't exactly hurt that Pine thinks
everyone should play D and D but what do
actual players think of the movie
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially turns out many of them really
enjoy it and they've taken to the game's
subreddit to express their joy in a
poster proclaims their love for Honor
among Thieves one ready to describe the
experience in the theater writing the
audience tonight for all Geeks surprise
and so the energy of the theater was
really upbeat there were even tear
jerker moments which I must give them
props for since that's hard to do in a
high fantasy film another subreddit
member found the communal viewing
experience similarly comfortable it was
a pretty full Theater which I was
shocked about and I didn't hear a single
person complaining about it apart from
the positive experience of seeing the
film with fellow enthusiasts several DND
aficionados have excitedly pointed out
specific details and references in the
movie
what is that again there's an owl there
they were particularly impressed by its
emotional impact but the experience of
Simply being able to see the movie as a
longtime DND fan is also important to
many another point of discussion in the
subreddits were about the way Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves manages
to marry its comedic moments with a
small heartfelt ones one Reddit sir
compared the movie's vibe to James
Gunn's work in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which has been known to balance
a similar line between laughter and
emotional gut punches they wrote It's
the DND fantasy Guardians of the Galaxy
film feel it's the best way to summarize
it it's not a comedy but there's
definitely some good comedy and
character writing with the jokes there
is also some genuine heart in it that
makes you care another redditor agreed
complimenting the movie's successful
balance between the serious and humorous
moments and compared honor among Thieves
favorably to recent superhero movies
better than the last four or five Marvel
and DC outings comedy was done well and
managed to take itself seriously when 2
and Joe to an appropriate without Marvel
level he is right behind me isn't he
detracting from serious moments follow
me to the orifice
the orifice
though it's clear that fans appreciate
the movie's comedy drama balance it
seems that the best part of watching the
film are still being able to share the
experience with their fellow players to
the point that even the movie's
occasional lower moments couldn't rain
on the parade one fun wrote it wasn't
perfect but the fact that everyone I
went with to see it which included 4 out
of six of my players and most of our
children a total of nine of us were
standing around and talking about it and
it took us all about 15 to 20 minutes to
leave the theater it's quite telling
they continue to say plus we were
talking with other random people in the
theater that loved it as well I haven't
felt that excited post movie since like
the first Matrix another user chimed in
to say if you are a fan of the game you
will love this movie well everyone love
this movie no I can see certain demos
that wanting to rush out to see this but
if you like DND it's a slam dunk this
emotional experience alone is clearly
enough to score Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves some serious
appreciation points from the fandom the
fact that it also happens to be a
genuinely good fun adventure movie
probably doesn't hurt either
anything you want to add
I'm good
[Music]
foreign